en este vídeo vamos a trabajar algunos
conceptos y vamos a comparar los de la
población con los de la muestra entonces
vamos a tener una especie de cuadro
concepto
el mismo para la población
como para la muestra
vamos a empezar con el más básico o el
más importante tal vez aunque todos son
importantes pero con el principal o con
el que se conoce primero que es el de la
media
la media en la población se representa
con la letra griega
y es la sumatoria de todos los elementos
del primero al último que los
representamos con la sumatoria de igual
a 1 de x psuv y desde igual a uno hasta
n sobre en es decir este este promedio
entre la sumatoria de todos los
elementos mientras que en la muestra lo
representamos con esta x barra y que
también es la sumatoria de todos los
elementos de la muestra que tomemos lo
representamos con una n minúscula como
para diferenciarlo de la n mayúscula que
son más elementos en la población que la
muestra ésta es pura lógica pero son
exactamente iguales las dos fórmulas
también vamos a tener el concepto de la
varianza
que para la población se representa como
sigma al cuadrado y que es la sumatoria
de uno hasta n mayúscula del cuadrado de
las diferencias entre cada uno de estos
valores y la media
y todo esto lo dividimos por n como para
promediar todos esos valores
de la misma forma dijimos que la
varianza de una muestra estaba dado
también por la sumatoria de esas
diferencias entre cada uno de los
elementos y la media de la muestra en
este caso al cuadrado
el cuadrado de esta diferencia en verdad
pero acá lo dividimos por n menos 1 como
para lograr una mejor estimación o una
a un valor que se acerque más a la
varianza de la población y en este vídeo
vamos a dar por conocido o vamos a
tratar de comprender un nuevo concepto
que es el de desviación ahora vamos a
usarlo con otro color
qué es el concepto de desviación
desviación típica
esta desviación típica antes que nada
vamos a ver para qué nos sirve bueno
esta desviación típica que es un
concepto muy importante porque nos sirve
para utilizarlo de unidad de dispersión
de los datos a qué me refiero con esto
bueno en lugar de medir con metros o con
centímetros como estamos acostumbrados a
medir vamos a medir estas dispersión en
las dispersiones que nos presenten una
distribución en unidades de desviación
típica entonces vamos a decir que la
dispersión es de tantas unidades de
desviación típica de dos unidades de
desviación típica de 53 y así
sucesivamente y es un concepto bastante
sencillo ya que es igual a sigma por lo
tanto es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza en este caso para la
población vamos a tener que esto es la
raíz cuadrada
de la sumatoria
de todos los elementos o de la
diferencia o del cuadrado de la
diferencia entre cada uno de los
elementos y la media sobre el total de
los elementos y lo mismo va a ocurrir
para la población para la muestra perdón
va a ser la desviación típica va a ser
igual a s que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza por lo tanto una
vez que tengamos la varianza vamos a
poder calcular sin ningún problema la
desviación típica y viceversa si tenemos
la desviación típica sin ningún problema
vamos a poder calcular la varianza vamos
a trabajar esto con un ejemplo
supongamos que tenemos
1 2 3 8 y 7 tenemos estos valores y
vamos a ver si nos veamos si esto es una
población si es población vamos si es
población
tenemos esta serie de datos y decimos
que es una población la media va a ser
un va a ser igual a la sumatoria de
estos 1 2 3 3 6 6 7 3 6 y 8 21 21 sobre
el total que 5 y esto nos da igual a 4,2
por lo tanto vamos a poder calcular
ahora
la fecha no vamos a hacerlo abajo vamos
a poder calcular ahora la varianza va a
ser igual al cuadrado de la diferencia
de cada uno de estos valores dividido
del total es decir 1 menos 42 al
cuadrado más 2 menos 42 al cuadrado más
3 menos 42 al cuadrado más 8 menos 42 al
cuadrado más 7 menos 42 al cuadrado y
todo esto
va a estar dividido el total de valores
es decir el total de n que es igual a 5
y esto no vamos a correr un poco vamos a
escribirlo abajo esto
es igual
que la varianza tenemos que es 38 8 es
la sumatoria de el cuadrado de las
diferencias sobre 5 y esto entonces es
igual a 776 ahora esto sí es población
veamos bueno antes que nada calculemos
ahora va a ver con otro color
a no ser tan monótonos calculemos ahora
lo que sería la desviación típica la
desviación típica en este caso sería
igual a la raíz cuadrada de la varianza
que es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 776
por lo tanto la desviación típica de
esta población dado por los números 1 2
3 8 y 7 es igual a 2,79
tenemos definido de esta forma a la
desviación típica
a la varianza
y a la media
todos los valores definidos por si esto
se tratase de una población veamos ahora
qué pasaría si en vez de ser una
población fuese una muestra vamos a
borrar acá
vamos a ver si es población vamos a
agrupar los valores
que no desaparezcan
vamos a ver si es población muy dijimos
que es igual a 4,2 la varianza es igual
y la desviación típica es igual a 279
veamos ahora qué sucede si esto es
población vamos si es muestra perdón si
es muestra
vamos a tener que la media va a ser
exactamente igual va a ser 4,2 no
cambian en absoluto la varianza
perdón la varianza de la muestra
recordemos que era s al cuadrado la
varianza de la muestra va a ser igual en
su numerador es decir va a ser 38,8 pero
el denominador va a cambiar va a ser n
15 menos 1 es decir vamos a escribirlo
acá 4
por lo tanto 38,8 dividido 4 nos da 97
ya que empiezan las diferencias
la varianza de la muestra es 97 mientras
que la varianza de la población es 7 76
son valores alejados pero no no tan
extremos y la desviación típica si esto
fuese una muestra será igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 97 que es igual a 3,11
por lo tanto
tenemos los valores y sabemos la forma
de calcular
cada uno de los valores para cada
concepto ya sea población o ya sea
muestran de manera sencilla podemos
calcular todos ellos